and we're going to do that again right
now lee mangyan is the virologist who
says she has evidence
about where this pandemic actually came
from
we're happy to have her on tonight
doctor thanks so much for coming on
hi hi patrick thank you thank you i know
that you've published some of your
research you're planning on publishing
more soon
give us for a non-scientific audience a
summary
of why you believe this virus came from
a lab in wuhan
please okay briefly from my first report
i can present the solid scientific
evidence to our audience
that this virus called a 196 virus
actually is not from nature it
is a man-made virus created
in the lab based on the china military
discover
and owned the very unique bad
chronovirus
which cannot affect people but after the
modification
becomes the very harmful virus
and now so i have evidence to show
why they can do it what they have done
how did they do it so
what you're saying is much
more sinister even than we've suggested
on this show than tom cotton
that almost anyone suggested you're
saying that the chinese government
manufactured this virus if i'm hearing
you correctly that's what you're saying
yes exactly based on the virus genome is
basically like our fingerprint
so you can see the very unusual
characters
in their genome which clearly based on
the
other evidence they left during the
modification
we can say finally these aids exactly
the one
come from their own special bad corner
virus
and then target human
what you're alleging is shocking more
even than i anticipated when we invited
you on
so i just want to ask the most obvious
question which is this genome presumably
is in the possession of many researchers
around the world why is nobody saying
this if it's true
yeah why there is nobody want to see it
it's because
of the big suppression come from the
chinese communist party
government and also their friend in
scientific
world so basically this is very clearly
that this virus is like frankenstein
so he created those things like
basically a cow
has deer's head has rabbitous ear
and also have monkey's hand so they can
never get
it from the nature and there were
evidence left in the genome
but the scientific world also keeps
silence
work together with chinese communist
party
they don't want people to know these
truths
also that's why i get suspended i get
suppression
i i am the target that chinese communist
party won't
be disappeared you're a brave you're a
brave person
um i i i'm giving the benefit out and
assuming you're not an anti-chinese
racist so it's not clear why twitter
would shut you down
or why you're being ignored by the rest
of the us media let me ask you a couple
of questions um
why would the chinese government
intentionally
create a virus like this okay if you
want to know the exact
motive the exact idea i think people
have to come to
ask them ask communist party
why did they do it because they are the
one to aid
we cannot always understand their evil
thinking
you have to come to ask them but what we
see
already prove that they have done that
it harmed everyone in the world lead to
the historic pandemic
involve everyone how do you believe this
virus
made its way from the lab in wuhan
outside
to the rest of the world okay
first as i said i haven't i have this
kind of solid scientific evidence and
also
my next report will come out soon to
make you fully
understand it is the other thing is i
work in the who reference lab
which is the top criminal virus lab in
the world
in the university of hong kong and since
i got deeply into such
investigation in secret from the early
beginning of this outbreak
i had my intelligence because i also got
my own unique network in china
involved the hospital intel institute
and also government also i work with the
top chronologists
in the world so together with my
experience
i can tell you this is created
in the lab this is from that template
owned by
china military and also it is spread to
the world
to make such damage to make such damage
do you believe the chinese government
released this intentionally on purpose
did they do this
yes of course it's intentionally and
even no need more evidence you already
can see
what they try to cover up from the early
beginning as i reviewed
in different medias before and also
what else they have done like making the
fabricated
virus to throw out the natural origin
theory censorship everything that every
evidence
point to the lab origins and also
clearly
try to make people like me want to talk
about the truth
get despaired
you know it's it's hard to be shocked in
a moment like this but you have
succeeded in shocking me unfortunately
this is not the forum for the details of
your research i don't have the grounding
necessary to ask you the right questions
this is when you
wish for a functioning media because
what you just said
completely changes everything we think
we know
about the pandemic that's wrecking our
country so i i really hope sincerely
that you will be doing many interviews
at american media and explaining this
in much greater detail i hope you'll
come back here doctor thank you so much
thank you everyone need to know the
truth yeah
shocking thank you